thank you
all right welcome back to the second uh
session of this Workshop my name is
ramco Van rostad I'm one of the
organizers and it's my great pleasure to
introduce me Hong Kang and she will be
talking about local limits and then in
particular about the interplay between
the locality and the global properties
of the random graph please go ahead
thank you very much for the uh kind uh
invitation and introduction
indeed I was not sure which talk I
should give because the theme of the
workshop or the whole semester program
turned out to be either grab limits in
the death sense or a local limits so I
craft talk easily about chromatic number
of dense graphones in the sense of the
Dan Cross talk
but then I realized that something else
is going on in this whole program named
the local weak limits if you were in the
boot camp we learned a lot about this
how important it is to have a good local
weight limit by the talk of sovik so
that motivated indeed this talk and the
title in particular so I will be
focusing on the very spots where the
graph sparsity meaning that the average
degree is always constant
and then our mostly focusing on this
interplay of local and Global structure
it can be anything
but then what if motivation of such a
title is the following that by now we we
all know that since the seminal work of
of edoshrani of course the giant
component
he is one of the leading films in the
theory of sparse random graphs
and it has long been observed that the
giant component is analogous to the
survival of the associated Garden Watson
process button muscle process is
something Global and on the other hand
this crystallizes this kind of analogy
crystallize the kind of the music
interplay between local and Global
structure because of the emergence or
the thresholds for the emergence of
giant components indeed determined by by
the average degree which is kind of law
config and this kind of motivates
and in particular in this yoga we'll
talk about two directions from local
properties to the global structure
meaning that you look at the local
neighborhood we know something about it
can we say something about the global
structure such as the giant computer we
see that there is a limit but also there
is a way to get out of it
turning our gear we I will also talk
about how the global structure
with the global constraints imposed on a
random graph changes or affects its
Global structure
of course when I give a talk about
sports random graphs it's so much
tempting and not to talk about the
address very result is something that I
cannot avoid I always start from that so
let's start from a very basic classical
result about the adults ready random
graph in the first part namely the
emergence of the giant by now we all
know but let me recap I'm gonna talk
about the original Ado should I need
random graph a model namely the
beautiful model gnm but I will switch
into GNP right now because it is easier
to present so we will think about uh
look at the edoshirani round number or
the sometimes we just called binomial
random raft to distinguish it from the
uniform model anyway so GNP and we will
be considering the number of vertices
contained in the largest component
and we let always a degree to be our
average degree D which is of course
equal to P times n minus 1 in this model
because for each vertex we have n minus
one attention neighbors and each the
property P will be indeed a neighbor
therefore this is the average degree and
we will always considered it's constant
and one of the most famous result by
abish Rani is about that if the average
degree is smaller than this is smaller
than one with high probability meaning
the probability tending to one
let's see
a older components are small in the
sense that they are at most of
logarithmic order on the other hand if
it is larger than one we do have a
unique giant component unique largest
component of linear order which
sometimes called the Giant
by now
this is not a surprising result in view
of let's say the universality principle
of the population Theory which says that
the cluster threshold
the giant cluster is indeed determined
by the local structure
and also its analogy to the Dalton
license process in the garden was in
process with the mean d we know that if
emergency is smaller than one number of
children expect number of children is
smaller than one the process starts out
on the other hand if the expected degree
is larger than one the process that
continues forever and and indeed this
kind of knowledge can be made rigorous
yeah
and using the survival probability of
the Galaxy wasn't fossil tree or
customer important process with with
with the person D we can indeed
determine the precise order asymptotic
order of the giant component as the
solution of the of the suggestions
equation is exactly marks the survival
probability of course
there is this analogy to make such
analogy work we have learned from Subic
stalk you you need to work harder it's
not just coupling with the with the
coupling of the component expose
exposure process with adopting lesson
three will not be enough we have to
apply the first and second moment as
well let's talk about the sprinkling
argument so in other words
in other words we need a little bit more
card although we know that there is this
a knowledge to look at the Muslim
process and that's the one thing that
that kind of motivates the rest of the
tool how such analogy is indeed was
discovered was already in the ITI
commercial Reddit paper about the uh
random hypercube or populated random
hypercubus and so on it has been a while
but it has been systematically
systematized partly due to carbon later
by other people yeah so let me just just
give you why this was the case using a
very rough idea about the local
structure is about everybody knows but
I'm just reminding you of what you might
have heard about in the past so we still
have average constant degree D and let's
choose one vertex uniform near random
from the vertex set of the universe and
you expose its neighbor of course
also the out degree is the number of
degrees warning there is the poisson D
and you select one neighbor of the root
and apart from all these small dust of
course this also has verbally poisson G
because it's likely that we will not
expose too much and so on and so on so
long as now it comes this uh this Ruth
description of the local structure so
long as we do not go too far away from
the root
that's kind of a not far away from the
roost kind of defines the radius of such
a ball which I will come back later so
so long as we don't go too far we know
that the average degree or out degree of
each vertex will be roughly Plus on D
this variable loose description of a
local structure but we can formalize it
this very simple spacing simple
observation can be cast nicely in terms
of the local reconvergence of the
benjamination as well as pipe and
reduction still today we have heard
about it already by Patton store and as
well as in the boot camp
what is it I will formalize it
said contribution goes back to to sets
of people then Germany Trump as well as
Alderson still
basically the object that we are looking
at is the so-called rooted graph say
it's a pair of a graph H and R basically
we are given a connected locally finite
if you look at locally it has the finite
the neighbors or if you look at only the
final radius number of vertices and
there is five that's what we mean by
localifying light globally it can be in
Philadelphia yeah so connected the
locally finite graph age in which we
select one vertex as a root
it's chosen I look at it and then I have
this kind of strange thing what it is it
is the so-called the ball of radius of R
so what is that given any
he puts the integer and any rooted graph
we will define an object namely the ball
of radius for L which is the induced
subgraph
induced this notation is induced it's a
breath
induced by the vertices of the original
graph whose distance to the root is and
most l
namely this will be the ball of radius
one wall of radius 2 all of this and so
on so we look at it such a ball will be
important concept to define the
solocality
furthermore we see two rooted graphs are
isomorphic
if there is an isomorphism from one
vertex vertex to the other isomorphis
meaning that the edge property should be
preserved yeah as well as the root
should be sent to each other
right inside Graphics morphism in
addition to the fact that the roots
should be sent to the another this
isomorphism so now it's a kind of basic
definition now I'm ready to Define what
local limit is
I'm not talking about the the metric
because they were too much
digitalization from the Christian stock
we of course know that how you measure
the distance between two rooted graphs
by the inverse of the distance blah blah
blah but I will not do in that formality
yeah so given a sequence of random
rookie graphs GN comma RN now for each n
g 1 RN G2 R2 we have a sequence of
random graphs rooted graphs
and we say another random rooted graphs
is zero are zero or g g o r something is
the local weak limit of of the sequence
gr or n we just denoted by such if now
comes the definition for each fixed
rooted graph H and HR
and for any integer l
the probability that the ball this is my
all the GNR right
the ball
is isomorphic to the given voltage graph
the probability that the ball is
isomorphic to the given graph converges
to the probability that the ball in the
limit
so another object is zero or zero is
isomorphic to R and H I kind of have if
you look at it correctly the if I look
at it as far away some of the edges this
are different they are identical to this
model I have drawn the same thing so if
I look at only the finite ball final
ball
they look the same isomorphic to Any
Given is it clear
some people call it convergence in
distribution but as Christian said in
his talk this is kind of a weaken notion
it's better to have convergence in
probability there is a such a version as
well if you are curious one of the
things that you can look up is the book
by by
yeah so this is a weaker version but
nevertheless it's not interesting it's
still interesting but if you want to
prove something stronger you need
convergence in probability but we will
be happy with it I will be happy with it
it's clear what we are doing
Now using this terminology the the
observation this loose observation about
the local structure of edosh ready can
be written very simply ah now looking at
the thing you might be able to think
that I'm talking about the sparse random
graph would know that if the average
degree is smaller than log n we know
that the graph is not connected but how
can we Define a local limit if the graph
itself is not connected then indeed we
Define such a thing as the local limit
of the component that contains the root
vertex
yeah so if the world does not consist of
one single connected graph but consists
of main components
and then the definition of the local
limit was equipped with this random
vertex and we're going to select one
vertex we need from the random from the
universe and we will see where it lends
in
the local mechanic of the comp component
containing the root
Now using this terminology now we are
ready to formulate just in one line in
this session
same as we consider Adobe GNP with
constant average degree it doesn't
matter which from 0 to Infinity
and we select one vertex uniform near
random as the root
then
the local limit of shreni is just
what is that is infinite tree generated
by a guten wasn't process with Opera
spring distribution poisson d
very very well known it's kind of
folklower but the proofs you can find
either by a paper by bamboo and
montanari or the book by Rebecca on the
outside picture it's so pretty
we can say that so I just didn't write
it just a reminder what what it means of
course if you understand this picture
you will see it often
but you can just think of this in
distribution
[Music]
no questions
I know okay very simple observation why
do we care about the constructors
no it's a very simple it's anything but
I already mentioned it has to do with
the yeah the local structure is is
related to the population threshold
relation threshold where the time closed
appears at least the the critical value
we can determine of course if you look
at the phased transition you have to
also discuss the critical window width
of the window window is not a local it's
kind of global you have to look at
critical exponents which usually related
in GNP a number of three components
outside Giant and so on and so on anyway
this is more Global but if you look at
only the critical critical calendars
where giant component appears namely the
critical threshold then indeed it has to
be with no construction even the average
degrees then I don't need to go that's
two I it's enough to have steps one
another thing that I mentioned I just by
passing of course a giant component in
order to study the size of the giant
usually there is a nice outpoint low
coupling
of the component exploring pressure
processed by the so-called breadth as
such you look at always its neighbor
start from enable it look at the
neighbor neighbor so for the breadth
first such
and you can complete from above and
below by Associated Garden lesson
branching process nevertheless
local structure local limit itself is
not enough to talk about the size and
the uniqueness of the giant it is
related but not so in order to have have
the information that we had earlier
we need to use usually yes it became
standard so I'm talking about standard
method usually first and second moment
first and second moment for the up Point
locally of the associated guidance
process but then it says about there are
potentially many large components but
then using the so-called sprinkling
you can say the uniqueness of the giant
merging them together so there are it
became standard but but anyway the the
starting point is as I said local
structure
second the advantage of this approach
this local structure is also that the
analogy to the higher dimensional things
are quite straightforward you can have
higher dimensional giant component
which allows many many overlaps
depending on the dimensions it can be
really nicely
extended subject to some hard work but
it's usually technical nature
but then also similar idea can also be
applied to structures with more little
bit geometric it's not exactly but sort
of geometric structure like a hyper
populated hypercube similar idea can
generalize to their and so on and so on
yeah even though simpler random Sim
share complexes similar ideas can be
applied
from local structure and so on and so
this is more combinatorial part and now
there are
other
kind of applications so-called message
passing algorithms today it was
mentioned already by peppers
all there is a very nice book by Mesa de
montanari on
information physics and computation in
which there are many many message
passing algorithms uh starting from the
local structure just to name a few
believe propagation it has been studied
a lot for example for the so-called
random case app where random coloring or
any random constraints constraints that
description problems and so on and so
many optimization problems and also
there is a simplified version which is
so called morning propagation algorithm
it's really simple if you are coming
from the combinatorics it has to do with
the so-called peeling process you peel
out the things that you don't want to
see
and you realize that you can construct
something such a thing is so-called
k-core which is the Maximus of graph
whose minimum degrees at least K so you
can achieve them by deleting the
vertices of degree and most K minus one
and such a filling process can nicely be
interpreted as the so-called one
propagation you just send the messages
to from the bottom to the top
and also recent work the rank or the
knowledge of a paratometrics or sparse
parametrics can be also studied by
harmonic propagation and I put here dot
dot because this is really a lot of
things are going on in this direction
but others
yeah this is why we care about the
structure
uh one thing and now I want to switch
from Global to local namely we want to
impose some Global constraint to a
random graph
of course one way is the imposing the
gulf information that we have seen from
Peter's talk but also not only the gulf
restriction maybe you impose even more
restrictive constraint namely I want to
consider only the planar graphs well I
want to consider the graphs thinking
that can be embedded on our surface
without Crossing edges such Global
constraints such a global constraints
had an effect to the global structure
namely the size of the Giant and outside
the giant but then as in turn it does
have an impact or effects also the local
structure indeed this I could have
studied from here but at first I want to
just give you some background on the
local construction any questions
why we care about such a global
constraints also comes from our master's
result
some 60 years ago already in the earlier
paper Edition Bernie proved the
following of course they proved the
things in gnm but but it can be
translated into GNP I want to consider
the same model that's why up to here
about the address ready
so if the consider the again the energy
random graph or the so-called binomial
random number of GNP when the average
degree is constant and not only the
giant component is small we know that if
the average degree is smaller than one
then each component is either a tree
or it contains it's a unicyclic meaning
that it contains only a single cycle
as therefore it is planar
with high probability on the other end
if you increase the p uh average degree
larger than one
then
it contains we have seen that unique
giant component but that giant component
contains at least two cycles with
sometimes call them complex furthermore
not only contains two cycles it is not
planar in longer so there are
topological copies of so-called K5 or
k33 so it is not planar so kind of this
motivates some of the people what can we
say about random grass with a polymeric
pulmonary constraints already if you
think about it
there is no nature there is a nature uh
binomial model with restrictions of the
planarity if you think about a little
bit more then it's very crucial to have
transition to comp direct comparison
with the glp and with the planaric
constraints
because of the edges are not any longer
independent it's not an easy thing so
switching from GNP to the uniform gnm is
easy two models are almost essentially
equivalent it is continuous if the
number of edges in these models are
the same let's say yeah for Simplicity
but there is no direct such a thing so
there is this switch from one model to
the other in case the planer is not
simple
on the other hand the planar graphs has
nice structure so what is more
convenient model in case of the planar
grab is indeed a uniform model it has to
be a lot of counting things going on so
I'm switching the model from binomial to
to none by no milk on purpose indeed so
I could have studied with the gnm but I
want to mention that because this Edge
dependency the things are much harder so
what I want to do in the rest of the
talk I will think about we will look at
the random words with the topological
constraints and we look at how there's a
topological constraint such as being
planar where it can be embedded on a
sphere without Crossing edges how much
it affects the global and local
structure of a random graph
such as the giant component or the
component structure or the local
electronic clear the questions to do
that let me set this here
that g is not a girl
it's a g will be denote a kind of genus
G will be any any non-negative integer
unless SG be the Oriental surface or two
dimensional surface with the G handles
it's the Taurus or two Taurus yeah g
handles is clear right and the model
that we will talk about the class of
graphs that we will talk about is the
set of all vertex labels the simple
graphs on N vertices with exactly
Energies
but they they are embearable of the
sphere in the physics Community often
they talk about planar graphs meaning
planar Maps meaning that it's already
embedded
we are not talking about the embedded
things
they have a potential to be embedded
yeah so there is a distinction a little
bit so we think about such a model and
we select one uniform near random SG and
M
a simple observation
is that the the simplistic case of
random graphs on the surface is when the
genus is zero this is just a planar
graphs the graphs that can be embedded
on a sphere without Crossing acids
that's of course anything that can be
embedded in a sphere without handle can
be embedded on a sphere with one handle
to handle and so on so it's like
incremental in terms of the genus and if
you don't have any restrictions on the
genus of course they are the whole world
who can having such a simple thing we
can turn our things everything in terms
of the cardinality namely the counting
things that's how we are doing things we
will do
very simple observations the address
random result about planarity can
directly interpret it in terms of this
right the fraction of the graphs they
can be embedded on the sphere versus to
the total number of graphs tends to one
so G ATP or gnm is planar with high
probability when the average degree is
smaller than one so for any M between 1
and N over 2 so meaning that this is
everything equal to one
fraction goes to one on the other hand
I mean when you had GNP
so it wasn't something I was thinking of
d as constant D was a constant now do
you want the ratio of M and N B again I
would restrict that yeah exactly I will
talk about that thanks so then why do
you subtract six as it makes it
objective yeah
that's coming here so um
we will not have any grafts on a surface
with them more than that many edges
digital order can I have them therefore
they are zero so the only case that are
interesting to our point of view is when
they ever produced between minuses
on that
and furthermore if I talk about random
routes on Surface with the genus G it's
very likely and because of the results
that are representing deal holes for any
genus in constant genus case so I would
just restrict myself to play the graph
to simplify the rotation instead of s0
and M I will just use P or player is the
location
pnm
where the arrangements are chosen here
for more than if I set the same
is that another thing so another thing
that is uh I have to mention is that
it's not my intention
this kind of thing hasn't been studied
already what kind of questions related
to random planar graphs and random
surfaces were already raised by Alan
fries in 80s but then it became more
popular in about 20 years ago due to a
very powerful and breakthrough
breakthrough I don't know but a very
interesting result because breaks were
happened later very very
motivating paper by results by Steger or
MacDonald
about 20 years ago in which they study a
lot about random planar graph how you
generate and how you sample them what is
the connectivity threshold and so on so
a lot of things were kind of initiated
therefore it became very popular during
the last 20 years but uh but on the
other hand the model that they look at
is the so-called n vertex model
not there but also the generalization of
their models most of the studied on
random planar graphs and random graphs
and surfaces
it's kind of uh deals with the so-called
n vertex model in which we do allow any
number of edges there is no restriction
on the number of edges yeah so just n
vertex chosen
then what what has been proved is that
indeed
typically a random n vertex model
is dominated by quite a dense regime
namely when the average degree is around
4.4
foreign
model is quite stable well it's well
ordered very stable structure namely
contains any given subgraph right it's a
planograph as a subgraph as well as the
giant component is is huge in the sense
that it covers nearly all the vertices
somehow it is far away from the edge or
any type sparsal regime
therefore we will indeed focus on the
regime which is more interesting is when
D is close to one close to one if you
look at the end model it's usually
dominated by the later stage when
average degree is full
nevertheless in view of the Ado sharani
random graphic tradition some 10 years
ago or even yeah some 10 years ago too
much and I look at what can we say about
the major transition in a random planar
graph
yeah so again
let me look at the planar graph we look
at the number of verses in the giant it
depends on on the average degree again
but surprisingly there are two critical
periods
their first critical period is when
average degree is equal to one equals
one which is analogous to the edge ready
we have seen that this additional
infected tradition has to do with the
average degree being larger than one was
smaller than one that we have seen
already so the first one occurs there
and I'll address to the edge running
on the other hand
when there is a second critical phase
when average degrees equal to 2 which we
haven't seen in the at the Israeli and
even hypergraph setting it's very
unusual thing about planar graph is when
average degrees is about two then giant
component covers nearly over vertices
already at the degree two this is and in
between
just a linear
linear so the fraction of the vertices
and the giant is just about T minus one
straight line
very strange vegetation is going on
uh and of course
this kind of Octavia affects also does
some other things
namely not only the giant components
shrinks
but the second largest outside the giant
will become larger
and indeed as a whole if you delete the
giant component from a learn and play a
graph the outside so for the fragment
sometimes called small parts or fragment
is critical so there is this another
effect going on due to the planarity
Penalty the edges that cannot be in the
giant component because of the crossing
edges potential covers images has an
effect outside causing other critical
behaviors even outside the giant this
was the global picture
first we study for planar graph and we
realized that we can extend it to any
constant genus but indeed that there is
even even stronger version that you can
extend such a result to any genus which
is smaller than that so called the
contiguity threshold of edoshrani and
random graphs on the surface
right things can be done as you can
imagine
there was such a straight line
it's unlikely that there is a very
simple Galton Watson branching process
approach
perhaps it's impossible to couple our
giant component with
rather simple
tree so it motivates what they are then
locally I zoom in
some of the point
and I ask myself how they locally look
like is it Garden masonry or something
else that has motivated me and indeed
the answer is the following
I just restring myself when the degree
is between one and two as I said because
this is the way the things are
interesting
then indeed if you select one vertex
uniformly random from the whole universe
then the local limit of the random
planar graph is a combination of two
linear combinations of two types
either gotten was intrigued with the
poisson mean one
or so-called skeleton trees and skeleton
tree is is just an infinite path
Infinity path
in which every vertex is replaced by
independent Watson 1 cartoon version 3.
in some sense Carlton was in One Tree is
T Infinity tree where there are just
starting from
it's clear so
plus I didn't understand yeah plus it's
a very strange thing because we are
talking about in distribution right it's
written here what we might Mind by this
notation it's just that for each fixed
rooted graph H and any any integer L if
you look at the probability the ball
of radius L of the planar graph yeah
probably the that is isomorphic to a
given graph
hence to probability
the garden wasn't one is isomorphic to
that times two minus one this is number
this is number this is a problem plus
ball around the skeleton trees
isomorphic to the given graph
scaled by D minus one
so you need a little bit of digestion
because this is not not offering how do
you how do you make a linear
combinations to Infinity treats right
but this is a kind of probabilistic they
defined in this fashion so that means if
I condition to be in a giant component
it's like T Infinity
exactly then this is indeed the kind of
a proof proof of idea is very simple I
told you indeed this local limit comes
completely from the global structure as
you said because the way we Define the
local limit allows that if you look at
the quenched local limit quenched
probability it will not be it will be
more complicated yeah because you have
to divide by random effect of the vertex
it's not if this is it is called weakest
version of the local limit as you said
already you hit it it really depends on
whether this randomly chosen root vertex
lies in the giant or the outside the
giant so indeed it happily the local
limit is indeed heavily depends on the
global structure I don't know the other
way around to be honest because I came
from from that one maybe some clever
younger people perhaps can come directly
to the local structure of a planograph
yeah which I don't see yet as you see
what we do is we look at the component
structure up of the planar graph again
set the scene so that we are all there I
always look at the random planar graph
with average degree tending to D which
is between one and two so this regime
one yeah the straight line regime
and S
will denote the small part of the random
planar namely you delete the largest
component
and look at it sometimes we call it
fragment yeah it's by calling MacDonald
and indeed the fragment
behaves similarly like a critical Edge
running random graph
in case of the classical edochrani
perhaps you all remember the fragment
namely the the graph outside the giant
behaves like a subcritical edoshrani the
so-called dual principle right if there
is also possible process the Dual person
process so there is a very night theory
behind the scene but surprisingly as I
said because of the planarity constraint
has an effect outside the giant as well
therefore the outside the giant that the
fragment behaves at the criticality
yeah
from the other end looking a little bit
going inspired by the proof of the
remco's local limit of the binomial
random graph GMP
you can indeed realize that indeed it's
not direct but you can compute those
things so that you can have a local rate
limit of the uniform at Oceanic graph as
well it's kind of easy
exercises then using their local limit
we can also show that indeed if you look
at the fragment only the local limit is
just Carlton Watson tree with Watson one
that's a criticality a solid one vertex
uniformly random if you look at the
local
question no work it's just a little bit
of a modification of the REM course
proof so yes agreement has shown that if
you look at a uniform random tree like
Kelly's theorem
then it's a skeleton tree right the
local limit is a skeleton so
how is this connector is this somehow
connected to this result that will come
late this is not a uniform tree
that's still the address really critical
and Australia
but they are a good intuition but if you
look at something else then premature
results will come surprisingly not
surprisingly perhaps if you look at the
internal structure of the largest that
you already hinted out it heavily
depends on this child component
structure so what is essential thing is
the so-called two core
it is kind of a very good good way to
look at the giant component depending on
your community but usually if you look
at the sparse random word from the
combinatorics community literally you
look at the two core and so-called
kernel and you build up the seeds so too
cool what is the two core we will look
at the not only the two codes everything
but we will look at times sorry we will
look at only the two core of the largest
components some sometimes the core is
defined or as the subgraph of the whole
graph whose minimum degree is at least
two because I'm Richard myself on the
giant with the giant yeah it's too
Horror in this home will be the maximum
subgraph of the largest component whose
minimum wage at least two if you haven't
looked at it because we have a different
Community how you create such a two
quarries you start from a giant
component you delete the leaves one
after another
then you will reach the core it's also
called pilling process
or in other words if you look at how the
things are attached you will immediately
realize that indeed the giant component
consists of the two core
in which every vertex in the two core
which is depicted in green are replaced
by rooted trees
foreign
component is indeed composition of the
two core
to the together with rooted trees
now if we select one vertex
uniform near random from the giant
component yeah we restrict ourselves to
be the fact that the root is chosen for
only from the giant component
indeed it will lie not in the full
vertex but outside why because there is
yet another structural theorem saying
that indeed the wood of the two core in
planar wrap is is sublinear In N
okay comparison to the other shreni in
the Edo shrenic when the average degree
is larger than one but constant any
constant in the two core is also linear
in that regime
yeah lean to core is bond together with
a giant but in planar the the linear
size to core is born indeed
not until average degree being two
perhaps I'll come back to the later
maybe somebody will ask so anyway in
this regime surprisingly the tuko is
quite small therefore if you select one
vertex video from your render will not
hit one of these with high probability
it will hit the vertex outside somewhere
now come back to your question now what
we can do is the following if we delete
the edges in the two core
which are depicted in the blue I delete
it what we get uniform random for rest
everything is a uniform uniform random
Forest but the result that he was
mentioning earlier is about three
so now it has to do with how many
components will be there what is the
size of the random Tree in this Forest
but the one can also show yeah therefore
it leads to the weak locally limit of a
random Forest it's not Direct
surprising if you need a one or two a
couple of pages to go there because
there are other details it's a direct
from the agreements result so we have to
a little bit be careful so we will get
the random Forest on N vertices with the
T many three components too many of
course this T number of three components
correspond exactly to the size of the
two core yeah I have only five minutes
huh oh maybe I will be done soon
now if you select one vertex uniformly
random then it will lie in one of the
three components of course
but then the distance what we can show
is the following is the number of three
component T is smaller order than N Sub
linear as in the two core then indeed
the distance between the root of the
chord to 3 that contains the root of the
forest is far away
now if you look at the Omega therefore
if you look at the local structure we
always look at the bowl of finite radius
it's like
looking at random tree so n as you said
so maybe I have to cut here so by due to
the grimage result we know that for any
random uniform tree the local limit is
skeleton tree sometimes you call it
scatter cast and tree
therefore you combine this together
just I can wrap up right in the previous
slide if you select your vertex uniform
random from the giant the local limit
will be T Infinity
on the other in the earlier slide we saw
that if we select one vertex root vertex
outside the giant it's the cartoon
wasn't one now if you select one vertex
view from the random from the whole
universe with probability D minus one if
it lands in the Giant
with probably 2 minus t it lands outside
that's how we prove things so now wrap
up the things
we have seen the phase transitions in
Edo shreni I have still here g m but
anyway to compare directly and I heard D
because it's from other slides anyway so
uniform random graphs had a very nice
vegetation following the cartoon
planar there are two critical periods in
between those linear and we have also
seen that the fragment of the Edo shreni
is a subcritical on the other hand
fragment of the random planar is
critical it's kind of interesting to me
and the psychologist is therefore of
order n to the two thirds not the
sub-linear logarithmic
and furthermore we have seen the local
limit of this type one of you might
already seen why mihan restricts herself
to D equals between one and two the
reason being that I don't know how to do
it
even we know that it should be the two
core threshold is when D is equal to two
but we don't know how to prove things
therefore I don't know yet how to do
this maybe some of you have a more
direct way to deal with local limit when
D is larger than two potatoes yeah thank
you very much for your attention
bulk
thank you very much for this beautiful
talk are there any further questions
yeah Shiva take the microphone is there
a Excursion Viewpoint of the proofs like
uh you can walk around the components
that would be nice but as I said this
model is quite new
[Music]
or fun popular well let's say open robot
is the end WordPress model it's easier
to handle but but kind of a Dynamics on
the on the random planar graph is not
just studied although in the very
original paper by Steger McDonald which
I mentioned they have defined this very
nice markup chain
on the planar graph by just deleting or
adding an edge subject to planarity this
Dynamic is there but nobody knows the
mixing time of such a simple Markov
chain event
okay
have a simpler process on it if you had
instead of PN M you had PNP
P then we could actually say let's say d
is 1.5 I could do percolation with
probability I don't know three quarters
or something and I'm still in the region
there for giant so what happens here if
on top of your graph D is 1.5 you do
percolation with some 1 minus Epsilon
where you just keep edges with this
probability yeah one minus Epsilon and
delete them as probability Epsilon we
haven't think about it maybe it's one
way of of doing that so if I return to
the original model p and p let's say
in order to study that what you have to
know is the What is the
is there concentration result on the
number of edges in PNP
[Music]
it's heavily dependent mother because of
the we don't know how many edges are
there so simply what you can do is GNP
subject to planarity if you write down
all these cooking things cooking recipe
then what will boils down is that you
can study GNP subject to planarity and
subject to its number of edges so the
subject to number of edges in PNP is not
easy we have a conjecture but it's not
that easy what is a even the expectation
what is the expected number of edges in
in in p n comma P when p is about G over
n
it's not easy it's strange number it's e
2 minus E times there is a conjecture
due to the kind of counting as you can
smell here behind the scene we are
counting a lot of things using the
so-called combinatorial LaPlace method
you count things very very precisely and
and and out of this counting formula we
have the conjecture on the expected
number of edges in PNP if you can do
that I think things will be easier but
we don't know and in terms of this
population perhaps on GN comma M now
still yeah I don't know maybe
I have to work on it I haven't think
about it populating on playing a pnm but
pnnp will be difficult
all right maybe in the interest of time
let's thank mihoon once once more
foreign